Making a movie is a strenuous process that
can take a toll on even the greatest of filmmakers.
They spend so much time analyzing each frame
for a long period of time, that they’re
just happy to get it out to the world. But
if they looked at their final cut one last
time before sending it off, they may have
been able to catch one last mistake. Here
are Screen Rant’s 10 continuity fails in
popular films.
Spider-Man
Peter Parker undergoes a tremendous physical
transformation when he’s bit by a radioactive
spider, and it takes some time getting used
to his new abilities. When he’s testing
out his web slinging powers in his bedroom,
he accidentally makes a lamp crash against
the wall. When Aunt May knocks on the door
to investigate the noise, that same lamp is
perfectly intact in the next shot. Since director
Sam Raimi had just shown it being destroyed,
you’d think he would have noticed this.
Chalk it up to the dangers of shooting out
of sequence.
The Avengers
Halfway through The Avengers, SHIELD’s helicarrier
is attacked by a brainwashed Hawkeye under
the control of Loki. It’s an exciting set
piece that kicks the film into gear and leads
to the Avengers assembling to save the world.
Even gravity couldn’t handle it all. When
Nick Fury tells Iron Man the helicarrier is
falling, a display Tony Stark is looking at
reads 15,000 feet. A few minutes later when
Fury looks at his own display, it says 18,000
feet. Which one is it really?
That’s left up to the viewer.
The Dark Knight Rises
Bruce Wayne loses his fortune after Bane forges
stock trades using Bruce’s finger prints,
and apparently Gotham City lost several hours
of time. When Bane and his henchmen arrive
to the stock exchange to complete their task,
it is clearly midday and light outside. But
once they leave with hostages on their motorcycles,
it’s become pitch dark – even though they
only needed 10 minutes for the transaction
to take place. It is true that Batman action
looks a lot cooler at night, but when a director
like Christopher Nolan is involved, audiences
expect more consistency. There’s no logical
explanation for the drastic time shift.
Star Wars
Audiences will always remember the first time
they saw Star Wars’ climactic Death Star
trench run. It’s a sequence that still thrills
to this day. One of its most tense moments
is when Darth Vader thinks he has Luke dead
to rights, but he misfires and hits R2-D2
instead. After the blast, the shot cuts directly
to R2, but the little droid seems 100 percent
fine. It isn’t until after Luke lands back
on Yavin that we see the effects of the impact,
with oil spilled all over R2’s body. The
special effects budget was tight on the original
film, so maybe they didn’t have time to
get a new shot.
Back to the Future
Marty McFly has to make sure his parents get
together in 1955, or else he’ll be erased
from existence. He uses a picture of him and
his siblings to see how long he has until
time runs out. Things are in dire straights
during the Enchanted Under the Sea dance,
as Marty begins to fade from the photograph.
It was such an important item, but Robert
Zemeckis had a tough time keeping track of
it. In the long shots featuring Marty playing
with the band, the picture is nowhere to be
seen. It’s only in Michael J. Fox’s close-ups.
Jurassic World
Moviegoers, and Chris Pratt’s Owen, found
it ridiculous that Claire spends the entire
movie running around the dinosaur amusement
park in high heel shoes. It seemed impossible
that she could survive the chaos wearing them,
but she did. Claire even found time to go
shopping for a new pair. While the shoes get
dirty as the movie progresses, they’re squeaky
clean when she arrives at the t-rex paddock
to unleash the original t-rex. When she leads
it to the Indominus rex, the shoes are once
again dirty. Since there was a line of dialogue
dedicated to the footwear, you’d think they’d
pay more attention to it.
Star Trek Into Darkness
When Kirk gets the Enterprise taken away from
him, he’s rightfully bummed out and decides
to spend his night getting drunk in a bar.
And he must have ordered quite a few rounds,
because the amount of beer in his glass changes
depending on the shot. When Admiral Pike comes
to check on Kirk, the young captain’s mug
is either full or almost empty. It’s an
obvious case of blending takes to complete
the scene, but since Kirk’s glass is in
the foreground of the shot, it would have
been nice if its levels were consistent. Kirk
liked to party, but not this hard.
Argo
The fateful moment in Ben Affleck’s Oscar
winner comes when the group is searching for
a screenplay to make their fake movie. Tony
Mendez stumbles across a script called Argo,
which has black vinyl covering and gold lettering.
It’s the perfect one for the CIA’s mission,
and Mendez was so excited, he must have ripped
that recognizable cover right off. In the
very next shot, as Mendez brings the script
out to his friends, the cover is missing.
Perhaps this is why Affleck got snubbed for
Best Director?
Goes to show that even Best Pictures have
imperfections.
Lord of the Rings: The Fellowship of the Ring
At the end of the first film in the epic trilogy,
the Fellowship has been splintered. Frodo
decides it’s best for the group if he goes
to Mt. Doom on his own, but his trusted companion
Sam is determined to go with him. As Frodo
begins to paddle away, Sam – who can’t
swim – runs into the water after his friend.
Sam begins to sink to the bottom, and Frodo
has to pull him out to save his life. Turns
out, Sam’s clothes were magic, since they’re
dry when Sam is back on the boat. Fans were
too caught up in the emotions to notice, but
it’s hard to miss.
Casino Royale
As 007 enters a poker tournament, he has to
create a password for the bank account to
deposit his winnings. The film reveals that
he chose “Vesper” as the password, after
the love of his life he met on the mission.
However, the film depicts Bond typing something
completely different. When he starts to enter
the password at the casino, the first key
he hits is 5, which typically has the letters
J, K, and L. Vesper contains none of those
letters, so did Bond just change the password
at some point during the game?
Anything’s possible for a super spy.
So what do you think of our list?
Which continuity errors make you scratch your
head?
Sound off in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!